walter pepper and chili lavinia billy
idol mahouty stevie wonder opus lolly
top hat right now i think i have about
36 turtles
i'm lori kramer i'm the turtle lady of
manhattan
i'm the only wildlife rehabilitator in
the city that works just specifically
with turtles
i rehab turtles
in an apartment in new york city
bringing turtles into the country
illegally has become big business i get
turtles from the department of
environmental conservation u.s fish and
wildlife the urban park rangers even by
policemen
last summer i had 680
baby turtles that were brought here from
the department of environmental
conservation
it's overwhelming to have a large amount
of turtles in a new york city apartment
i promised my husband a bathroom and a
bedroom without turtles
the bath bathroom is where we take our
showers and it's a people bathroom
if i lived outside the city and i had a
yard i probably would be rehabilitating
all kinds of wild animals
but here in manhattan turtles are
perfect
when i was a child there was no place
for women in vet school but somehow
things come full circle
i'm a turtle nurse that's basically it
i think that i get good turtle points in
heaven
you